حقيقه نعم الوضع حاله ماساويه تعم المنطقه
الشماليه بعمل المنطقه الشماليه والشماليه
الغربيه والشماليه الشرقيه من سوريا اضافه
الى جنوب تركيا نتحدث حتى الان عن حصيله
غير نهائيه
125 مدني كانوا قد لقوا حتفهم جراء هذا
الزلزال النصيب الاكبر كان لمدينه
الاتاريف حلب هناك خمسين او اكثر من 50
مدني كانوا قد لقوا حتفهم جرائه انهيار
الابناء السكنيه اضافه الى اكثر من 350
حاله مصاب تم وطبعا اتحدث عن ارقام غير
نهائيه وغير دقيقه مئه بالمئه هذا ما
تمكنا من الحصول عليه من النقاط الطبيه
وبعض المصادر وايضا المستشفيات وعمليات
النقل ما تزال هناك الكثير من المدنيين
العالقين تحت الانقاط تحت ركام المنازل
المهدمه في المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه من
سوريا الحكومه السوريه المؤقته اعلنت حاله
الطوارئ الدفاع المدني يلعب رئيس حربك
بعمليه اخراج المدنيين من تحت الالقاب
الامكانيات
التي يمتلكها اضافه الى فرق المنظمات
الانسانيه والمدنيون الذين يشاركون
بالادوات البدائيه من اجل ابعاد الانقراض
عن المدنيين نتحدث عن مناطق منكوبه بشكل
كامل اتحدث عن سرمدا اتحدث عن مدينه حارم
وايضا سلقين المناطق القريبه من الحدود
السوريه التركيه النقاط هناك النقاط
الطبيه تكتظ باعداد كبيره من المصابين